the interview we let format is a bit
different and what this means is that
usually in the beginning the interviewer
will give you a bit of a context a bit
of a situation and we'll describe the
overall problem for you so for instance
you might talk about a business give you
some specifics on that business and now
we'll ask a rather open question of what
this business should do to improve its
profits now the interviewer will expect
you to now ask questions through the
interviewer about additional information
that you not want to have in order now
to come to a solution so here or do not
wait that the interviewer gives all the
relevant information to you but you're
not supposed to really ask to ask the
interviewer all the things that you
believe are relevant all the things that
you want to know to not come to conclude